you know I don't think that a man who evades questions
about how many abortions he's paid for
should be preventing other people from getting them right
Donald Trump values his right to privacy
he didn't wanna answer that question from Warren Dad when he was asked
why doesn't that right apply to other Americans and to all Americans
this isn't just an anti abortion agenda
this is an anti sex agenda
if you look at Project 2025
they don't just wanna restrict abortion
they want to ban pornography
I have quotes here pornography should be outlawed
quote the people who produce and should be imprisoned for young women
young men right
who do not wanna see their sex lives regulated and wanna keep the
keep their you know
internet browser private this isn't just control of women
it's control of you too and men men are included